je vous présente aujourd'hui christophe
felder et camille lesecq qui ont fait un
ouvrage sur la pâtisserie et surtout
principalement sur les gâteaux donc
christophe felder est un grand chef
pâtissier qui a un peu
innover un peu dépoussiéré tout ce que
pouvait être les desserts dans les
grands dans les grands restaurants donc
c'est un voilà c'est une personne
enfin c'est un chef pâtissier reconnu
par ses pairs
donc aujourd'hui ils ont donc rédigé à
quatre mains un ouvrage qui est sûre les
gâteaux mais pas seulement
donc en fait c'est toute une visite de
la france et de ses régions et donc de
ses desserts et ses gâteaux donc en fait
l'intérêt de ce livre entre autres
choses c'est pas seulement d'avoir des
recettes c'est un peu de voir chaque
région et calais le gâteau qu'ils soient
un peu l'emblème ou un peu le porte
drapeau de la région
donc ces livres en plus de nous avons
des très très bonne recette nous montre
aussi de très très belles photos de
gâteaux sur ce qu'on pourrait faire si
on avait 15 ans derrière notre cuisine
mais voilà donc l'ouvragé en soi a aussi
son intérêt dans toutes les photos de
ces jolis petits desserts et de ses
fameuses région qu'on peut voilà visiter
la france vis-à-vis de ses desserts et
donc point a ajouté aussi c'est qu'on va
recevoir christophe felder à la
librairie le 11 décembre vendredi donc
un vendredi soir partir de 17h donc il
sera parmi nous pour signer et
rencontrer et discuter autour des
recettes qu'il a peu qu'il a pu créer et
voilà et pour échanger avec lui durant
un moment un petit moment de
convivialité
c'est le début d'une série
on suit une jeune fille qui a des
parents un petit peu particulier son
père tous les mois au moment de la
pleine lune disparaît faire des chasses
dans un château avec ses amis
cette jeune fille elle ressent des
choses un peu bizarre quand elle voit
par exemple dracula au cinéma et qu'elle
voit du sang coulait ressent des choses
étranges la première fois qu'elle
embrasse son petit ami elle le mort
voilà en gros la nuit dans paris au
moment de la pleine lune
les loups garous se réveille et se met
en quête de proies il ya une question
d'héritage autour de 7
de cette histoire également en fait la
famille des loups garous a besoin d'un
nouvel élu on imagine assez vite que
cette jeune fille va être la fameuse
élus mais elle en a absolument aucune
enfin n'a absolument pas conscience
clairement les loups garous tout ça pour
elle c'est du mythe
donc voilà c'est une bd fantastique un
petit peu gore mais voilà c'est bien
mené il ya une histoire policière
derrière parce que évidemment il ya des
meurtres dans des conditions un peu
étrange donc la police s'intéresse à
toutes ces disparitions
voilà je présente aujourd'hui aux nuits
au mes yeux de la main lamia ziadé qui
est une libanaise francophile et
francophone
donc c'est tout enfin c'est un roman
illustré qui est parcouru par énormément
de toutes ces gauches enfin tout ce que
toute la production elle et qui parcourt
toute l'histoire du moyen-orient
donc ça commence en 1900 ça finit en
1970 donc on parcourt toute la vie
culturelle et toute la vie artistique du
moyen-orient que ce soit le liban
l'egypte la palestine et donc on
découvre comment était
quelle est cette richesse et tout ce
faste qui a pu y avoir durant les années
50 au moyen-orient et comment ça s'est
répandue sur la planète entière donc il
ya toutes les connexions du cinéma avec
hollywood il ya toutes ces connexions
avec la peinture
on voit aussi toute la vie toute la vire
au tracé de oum kalthoum
donc on voit comment est là comment elle
s'est installée dans le paysage et
comment elle a vécu là la révolution
égyptienne
l'intérêt de ce livre n'est pas
seulement dans tout cet historique de et
toute la densité artistique puis
foisonner durant les années 50 et même
avant au moyen-orient l'intérêt aussi se
trouve dans toutes les gauches de
l'auteur donc comme je l'expliquais dans
le livre il ya toutes les pages sont
finalement illustré par des gouaches cas
café l'auteur on dirais pratiquement des
pastels enfin c'est un très très beau
coup de crayon
donc voilà donc on voit d'un côté tout
c'est toute cette vie illustré par un
roman et on voit où tu si toute cette
vie illustré par par tout les goûts âge
qui parcourt qui parcourt le libre c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune femme le
quarantaine d'années qui s'appelle
camille
un soir elle rentre du travail
elle est fatiguée elle tombe en panne au
milieu de nulle part
évidemment elle sort de sa voiture il se
met à pleuvoir elle a pas de réseau donc
c'est la cata elle était déjà proche de
craquer et là elle n'en peut vraiment
plus elle va sonner à une porte trouve
une maison sur le chemin il ya une
grande bâtisse qui apparaît et les gens
qui l'accueille sont très chaleureux
très gentil et elle traque elle déballe
tout tout ce qu'elle a sur le coeur les
problèmes au travail les problèmes avec
son mari les conflits avec son fils etc
et il se trouve que l'homme à qui elle
confie tout ça et routine aux log qui
lui explique ce qui va pas c'est que
c'est la routine il faut que vous
appreniez à voir la vie du bon côté et
il va lui donner plein de petites
astuces comme ça c'est gratuit jusqu'à
ce qu' elle estime qu'elle va mieux et à
ce moment là elle estimera
prix que je mérite cette thérapie entre
guillemets est ce qui est intéressant
dans ce roman au delà de l'histoire
c'est que nous en tant que lecteur on
peut prendre plein de petites pistes en
fait faire des listes le matin de ce qui
serait bien de faire elle elle fait des
concours de grimaces avec son fils
histoire de se détendre avant de partir
au travail
voilà c'est plein de petites astuces
comme ça qu'on peut appliquer à son
quotidien